if not I will give the floor back to
Minister Farrakhan and for one more very
important item thank you
before we close the press conference I
would like to take this opportunity to
thank my friend Commissioner Tyson for
her service services mariana over the
past five years you have worked very
hard to European social policy and for
European world workers as you term in
the Commission nears its end I just want
to thank you for your energy for your
engagement and for your commitment you
are an inspiration to us all thank you
very much Madam President and as I said
in the Indian Ministry meeting we had
good results and I'm very proud on it
but we only have those results because
we worked very well together and it was
really nice working with with all the
people in the APSCo circle thank you
very much so in that beautiful note I
think it's time to wrap up the press
conference thank you everyone for coming
thank you also for those of you who are
following this online and a warm thank
you to our interpreters I wish you all
safe travels
see you soon the press conference is
closed thank you